foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right I am ready I think my crew are
ready as well go ahead and open up the
door if you would please and let people
in folks you are tuning in to daily with
Doc where we have a live presentation
that you can come and join us and ask
questions of the one the only Dr Joel
Wallach join us here on Zoom at Daily
with Doc zoom.com that is Monday through
Friday from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time
so if you're in Eastern time that is
three o'clock your time if you are eight
hours ahead of us it's eight o'clock
your time p.m so folks feel free to join
us here on daily with Doc my name is
Becca dukes and as the hostess of this
show I am honored and it is a great
privilege to be able to bring to you
empower powering information now the
information you're going to be hearing
today
changed my life and that's why I am so
insistent and confident in being able to
share this information with all of you
if somebody shared this program with you
make sure that you get back with them
tell them thank you and ask them what is
your next step to help reach your
optimal goals when it comes to your
health and for some it may also include
some financial goals that
this program can actually help you with
as you are serving a greater purpose
more than just building an income but
actually helping people within your
circle of influence and around the world
because it's not just belly to Bell
anymore folks as we know since we have
zoom right now
we have the ability to reach anybody and
everybody who has an internet connection
there's quite a few people
and it could be you
that talks to somebody who talks to
somebody who talks to somebody or speaks
with gotta get the grammar thing right
that changes somebody's life in an
amazing spectacular way so we invite you
to join us here on this Crusade as we
are sharing information
about what you can do in your own life
with the guidance of Dr Joel Wallach now
we do take questions so if you are here
live with us and you would like to ask
some questions please make sure you find
that raise hand option in the zoom menu
just click on raise hand and I'll be
calling on people in the order that
their hands are raised if you're out on
YouTube or Rumble we do have the amazing
AGA sportas who is helping keep track of
those questions as well
so feel free
to your questions
um
you know it's
there's a lot of people out there that
are sharing information
it's hard to know what to believe who to
believe
but until you try it for yourself folks
you're not going to know how amazing it
feels to be on a 90 for Life program so
I definitely invite you to listen up be
a sponge absorb the information that is
shared on today's program and be ready
to think about who you could help whose
life needs what you are hearing today
now this program is sponsored by
dailywooddoc.com daily withdoc.com is a
group of independent youngevity
Associates who have a passion for
helping people we are just a small part
of a very large community a large family
of people who have that same passion and
we want to make sure that this resource
is available to everybody and make sure
that folks if you were shared this
program with somebody you get back with
a person that shared it with you
now the content of this program is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician the FDA requires us to
let you know that the facts that are
shared in the statements that are shared
on this program have not been validated
by the FDA and our products are not
meant to treat
diagnose or cure any specific diseases
but folks the person that we have with
us today has sued that organization
eight times with victories
those victories had have led to the
essential addition of nutrients into
things like baby food
that has had the cause and effect of
fewer
greatly reduced amount of Sids here in
the United States
and many many other different or health
conditions of all ages so listen up
what mustard is fee
I
I'm not getting to you yet just be
patient sir okay
you you can say words that I'm not
supposed to be able to do because you'd
have that Dr in front of your name I'm
just a certified holistic health coach
and you know director of student
services
I don't know that I want that Dr label
thinking about it but I don't know
but let's get to today's program folks
again
on our on our program today
you're going to want to take some notes
but Dr Wallach speaks fast
if you're here live with us make sure
you have that chat open because we have
an amazing typist as part of our co-host
crew and she is sharing information and
even putting into the chat what Dr
Wallach is going to be recommending for
the individuals that ask questions on
today's program now because of HIPAA
laws we do not have that as the as
a savable chat so you can take a
snapshot of it or a screen share
screenshot of it so that you can take it
then to your health coach or the person
that shared this program with you and
say hey this person had a lot of the
same things that I had going on this is
what was recommended help me get it
okay and it also includes the dosing on
most of what she types in as well so
be prepared but if you don't listen as
fast as he speaks or take notes as fast
as he speaks we do have our replays on
daily withdoc.com and that includes the
replays going all the way back for three
years when we started ask doc live that
was just a Friday program so the fact
that we're bringing Dr Joel Wallach to
you Monday through Friday for a whole
almost hour
is is pretty spectacular in
meeting a need that people were looking
for so now without further Ado I would
like to introduce to you and bring on
with with me
one of the founding fathers of the
science of epigenetics that proves the
genetic theory of disease transmission
is incorrect and we have more control
over our health then the medical
community wants us to believe Dr Wallach
welcome to daily with dog well thank you
Becca and thank you team it's um very
exciting time and again just briefly to
add a few things what Rebecca said uh
going back to nineteen
uh let's see here 63 I discovered the
first mass die off in America from
pollution 500 sheep died in one night
they were healthy perfectly healthy
until that night they were farmweight
farmer wakes up the next morning they're
all dead he brought me 50. I was a
student working my way through
veterinary school as a student
um uh employee in the Pathology
Department and all it was a Christmas
time during 1963 and all the professors
were gone so this this
farmer dumped 50 dead Lambs on me he
said well I had 500 healthy ones
yesterday they're all dead this morning
they're all what
all 500 were dead okay there's a
perfectly normal yesterday they're all
jump in and out of the feed bunks and
following the wagons and making their
noises and laughing and doing what sheep
do and today they're all dead I said
well gosh let's have a look here so I
opened up the 50 deadlams and their
blood was black not dark red but black I
said do you have other farms around you
said yeah I'm surrounded by Farmers or
what kind of animals they have none they
all raise grains and hay and I said oh
what kind of fertilizer do they use well
you said they use nitrate fertilizer I
said I need some of the water from the
pond or the trenches or wherever these
sheep were getting their water so he
gives a phone call and an hour later one
of his employees comes with a bucket of
that water from that that pond
they had enough nitrates in there to
kill a million people okay and because
of the runoff from their surrounding
Farm to the fertilizer got written up
submitted for publication and Marlon
Perkins the old Mutual Omaha while
Kingdom show
um sent me to Africa work on the White
Rhino conservation project that was my
first post-doctoral Fellowship I was
supposed to find out why all why Coronet
Rhino were dying and um I've got that
figured out and we established two
um White Rhino game parks for them and
set up everything so they have permanent
water and feed and all that kind of
stuff and I'm prepared to stay in South
Africa the envelope game reserve forever
I'm having the time of my life I
delivered my second baby out there
myself on the out you know in the in the
Felts if you would in Africa and um
because it was a great time in my life
and well Marlon Perkins uh he took that
paper that I wrote when I was in Africa
he took that paper that I wrote and
submitted it and got a 21 million dollar
Grant from the National Institutes of
Health to do a big study worldwide study
he called me back said you're gonna be
the pathologist in the city of Wallach
you don't refuse Marlon Perkins so I was
reluctant but I came back and sure
enough over a 10 year period I did 20
000 autopsies published it was about 20
different
um unique Publications on diseases that
we found out the cause and forensic here
for and also
um found the cause prevention and cure
for several things okay and this was
very exciting so
um he what should I say it's one of
those things were
because of that history and all my
things my thesis was in the Smithsonian
Institute yet today as a National
Treasure it sells her twenty five
thousand dollars each we do have a
um which I say a summary of that thesis
that sells for twenty five thousand it's
called epigenetics we started a whole
new science of heavy tanks to replace
the sense of genetics there are no
genetically transmitted diseases G's eye
color skin color hair color gender
that's it there are no diseases that are
caused by bad genes that's what doctors
would say when they didn't know the
answer they might say I don't know say
oh it's your genes causing a problem
okay
and so that was kind of exciting this
one sells for 25 bucks not 25 000 but
you get the same information so I urge
everybody to have this at least one of
these books in their family and then
I got a job working for the Yorkies
primate Center at Emory University in
Atlanta Georgia and I was only there for
a couple of months I ran into the first
uh non-human case of physical bro says
make long story short I found out there
was not genetic as I said and one of
those birth defects of the associate you
know simple nutritional efficiency and
they fired me because they said it
wasn't genetically everybody knows it's
a genetic wall if you can't say that so
they fired me
and that's when I went back to school
and became a nature physician I taught
nutrition there and I said I might as
well get the degree so I started taking
courses and gave me some credit for some
of my basic agricultural sciences and
veterinary sciences and so I was able to
get that degree in three and a half
years instead of four years okay and so
anyway huh
I'm sorry to interrupt you but this book
right here primates
talks about that with a cystic eye
process and it's a it's a chapter out of
the book diseases of exotic animals yeah
I think it's I think it's on page the
206 or something like that yeah you want
people to start on page 206 yeah right
here talks about the cystic fibrosis
yeah read that first and then go back to
the beginning of the book but that tells
you a lot of stuff the doctors don't
know and why we're doing what we're
doing okay that book just came out a
couple of months ago very proud of that
Liddell did a great job
and
and can get this look at
drjwalik.com it's called primates okay
now I want to keep going here because I
got more exciting news I'm limited if
you're giving that eyeball okay
what I can say here but we know the
cause prevention and reversal of
Alzheimer's disease we know that cause
prevention reversal of
um
um see here the disease called multiple
sclerosis multiple sclerosis of the
spine is called
um what
Dion Beret Guillain-Barre syndrome very
good you get an A plus okay and
gambrinosity gambler syndrome is just Ms
his spinal cord and that's preventable
and reversible we know the mechanism
there
and then we also uh know how to
um
prevent reverse other brain and
neurological diseases you know and heart
disease and high blood pressure and
diabetes and
macular degeneration all this stuff is
just nutritional deficiencies okay now
here comes another one which I'm not
going to mention yet so you can relax
I'm not going to mention it okay I'm not
going to mention it but we're at the
point now where we have some really
heavy duty evidence to support our
um which I say matter of belief but our
facts okay which point a different
direction that is the current belief in
the medical system and so we have
unimpeachable facts okay because it's
facts that they collected okay they
can't say well we screwed up for all
this time okay we're not saying that
what we're saying is we have new
information we're going to share that
here as soon as we it's probably within
the next couple of weeks and we're going
to take all these diseases
yeah and you look at somebody like um oh
um
let's see here
uh oh look Lou
so Garrett Lou Garrick yeah Lou Gehrig
Lou Garrick disease Lou Gehrig disease
was named after what
oh it's ALS ALS amalotovic lateral
sclerosis well if you know what a
myelotrophic means okay that means the
myelin of the brain was trophic which
means it was gone the mild and the white
man of the brain was gone okay and
um
they gave him two years of treatment the
Advanced Medical treatment he was a top
baseball player I don't know for about
15 years he had more home runs and Babe
Ruth and all this kind of stuff and he
died after two years of treatment
PLS ALS you know they renamed after him
okay Lou Gehrig's Disease because he was
the guy and he was going to you know run
around and raise money to find the Cure
and he died following their treatment
before they found the Cure well I found
a cure I I know what it is okay and it's
very simple and we're using that as kind
of a kickoff for this other disease
we're talking about which I'm not going
to name yet
I'll give you a hint one of the symptoms
of this other disease is pill rolling
people sit there it's it's kind of a
which they say it's kind of a Tremor but
it's particularly the thumb and the
forefinger so you know that there's a
certain part of the brain involved when
when you get a picture like that they're
sitting there doing this all the time
they're they're not consciously doing
that there's a brain tell them to do
that it's called pill rolling okay and
it's it's diagnostic for a particular
disease well I know the answer because
we now have through one of our health
coaches access to somebody who had that
disease for 14 years annual physical 11
years
for 11 years okay positive positive
positive positive negative that can't be
right do it again negative okay
um oh okay
um let's see here we'll see you next
year keep doing what you're doing bye
okay well we're putting all this
together we're going to run it by our
attorney I I left a message with the
attorney that we're to be running
something by you pretty soon here so we
once you're okay on this get it done
correctly because we're going to
eliminate another disease I'm the guy
that eliminated physical brosis I'm the
guy that eliminated mustard with Jerry
Lewis one of her great and Navy Seals
okay
um
Marvin Rob okay for the three of us
actually did the the thing with with
monster history and when Jerry Lewis
took it to the most Disney Association
on Saturday the 4th of September 2011
they summarily fired him
okay similarly fired Jerry Lewis that he
put a gag order on him so he couldn't
say anything and then the next day the
the fifth of September 2011 they shut
down the teletime and he had raised 2.6
billion not million 2.6
billion dollars for the most history
Association through that Telethon and
they they killed it the day after they
fired Jerry Lewis because they didn't
want to hear that we had found the Cure
well that's what they're raising all
this money for and we actually found it
for him and when we took it to him they
fired Jerry Lewis shut down the Telethon
and it was a big who let me tell you
well that's what we're kind of creeping
along getting every everything in ducks
in a row and so forth and so we're
deciding whether or not you know we're
going to make this is going to be like
all discoveries like this it's going to
be a big announcement big you know
article scientific publication sort of
background but after that
are we going to add that to one of our
existing books are we going to have just
a separate book for it we'll make that
decision after we talk to our health
coaches and and our attorneys and so
forth and we'll see which way we're
going to do it but it's going to be
a big deal
this is a big deal because every country
in the world is going to benefit from
this we're going to save thousands of
people a day around the world right now
there's one million of these patients in
America
that have this disease there's one
million patients that have a disease
there's 50
new ones every excuse me every year
and there's 35
000 die every year from this disease so
just for this information is coming out
here in a few weeks
is going to save
a million people
and stop
99 of all new cases so we're very very
excited about this we already know the
answer but we have to go through the
steps to make sure that we're not
stepping on toes and getting ourselves
in trouble but I'm very very excited and
I cannot thank Rebecca and one of our
great health coaches
can we say her in her first name
okay we're not even say our first name
okay I would love to because she she's
done a lot she's done she's done great
but we can't mention any name stock okay
now I have to tell you that I sent
um Rebecca and this health coach
um the how to solve this disease problem
and Rebecca recorded it so there's no
doubt what I said when I said it okay
I'm the guy who said it okay and this
right you still have the recording
correct oh absolutely Dr Wallach but the
important thing is is
because of your recommendations
people are able to fill
better outcomes
that's that's the important part
and that just goes to prove that in all
of your research that when nutrient
deficiencies occurred
so did different Health poor health
conditions
over 600
yes
and it's really sad because doctors
would always say this is a genetic thing
this is an autoimmune thing there are no
gently transmitter diseases there are no
autoimmune diseases as soon as they say
that you excuse yourself and say I need
to see another doctor for another
opinion
bye oh by the way don't Bill me because
I won't pay it
quite that easy Dr Wallach but folks
let's go ahead and we have so many
questions that are coming in whether
it's here on YouTube here in the zoom
room through people signing up for our
newsletter and submitting their
questions there
and also going to daily with doc.com
using that contact option from the menu
and submitting us an email with their
questions there so I want to make sure
that we get through those and it's not
all about quantity it is about quality
we want to make sure that because
everybody is unique and special to us
that they get the time deserved but my
first question Dr Wallach is coming off
of YouTube
and this individual's I think sister
sister or niece
um was told by their Midwife that coming
close to the end of
pregnancy for labor to stop taking
essential fatty acids now I know
essential fatty acids are nature's blood
cleaner blood thinner
but what would be your response to stop
taking them all together
well that would be like saying stop
taking oxygen
okay that's how incorrect that statement
is
okay essential fatty acids by the very
nature
are essential
okay and they not only prevent blood
clotting but they also
sustain the health of the cell wall of
every cell in your body whether it's a
nerve cell or heart cell or kidney cell
muscle cell intestinal wall cell they
all require that essential fatty acids
so that good things food can get in and
the bad waste products can get out it
actually helps with the function of cell
walls it's more than just you know blood
thinner and so any doctor to say oh you
can stop taking the essential fatty
acids why on Earth would anybody do that
this is like saying you know I know
you're an athlete and everything but you
can't have oxygen anymore
um
so after birth you know there there is
or there is quite a bit of bleeding we
don't want to have an excessive amount
so it's can taking the efas create that
excessive amount where there's no
clotting
okay here's the secret
you have to take all 90 essential
nutrients
you can't say well I'm just going to eat
well I'm gonna take a lot of this that's
not how it works you take a lot of
everything you don't take a lot of just
this and just eat well to get all the
other stuff you need uh they tried that
for a long time and they had all these
birds effects and everything and as soon
as Jonathan's name order a great
attorney and I sued the FDA and federal
court
eight times we prevailed and doctors
were standing in the way they're saying
you can't put those vitamins and
minerals in the baby Farmers I came from
Milton semi because it'll cause the
babies to die
they're poisonous
where are they getting this stuff okay
okay so that's why we sit in federal
court and there you go okay
and uh it took 35 years because they
fired me over that okay and so 35 years
later I get to cloudy schwartzword and
that's Dr gerhorn the world's expert in
trace minerals particularly selenium
putting the gold medal on me for the
cloud schwartzward I was breathless
because to have him personally put that
on me that's like being an angel of God
and having a God that comes out and come
and have a cup of coffee with you okay
so holy moly okay they have this guy
personally present that gold medal on me
and I just I just I I don't know what to
say he he was a champion and he always
did what was right and he was a
professor many universities including
University of California
and he was really one of the most
intelligent
men ever knew when it came to
biochemistry he he could repeat
everything for every Trace mineral every
nutrient and so forth in every
biological process and every cell in the
body which is he had a brain it was
unbelievable so to have him
um
uh actually and he and and um
Barry commoner from the head of the
Department of biology at Washington
University and and um let's see here in
Missouri not Washington yeah it's
Washington University of Missouri right
it's like Washington the president not
you know not Washington State okay and
then of course
um the director of the St Louis Zoo and
the head of the TV program okay
um Marlon Perkins they got that grant
that 21 million dollar Grant okay that
and they called me back from Africa to
be the pathologist on that product that
was a that was a big deal okay that was
a big deal okay for
1966 okay I believe it was 66 or 67 okay
and just think about that that amount of
money in 1966 1967 that was more money
than most countries had for an annual
budget okay and so that was a big big
big big deal that was a big deal and so
I was just so honored and proud that
they remember they remembered me but
they did use that the publication that
was my first scientific publication I
wrote when the 500 sheep died and you
know I'm just 23 year old student you're
trying to work my way through school and
I get these 50 dead Lambs dumped on me
and that was the beginning of all this
okay
well Dr Wallach
they can act people can actually find
that reward that award that was
presented unto you they've made up a
nice little pamphlet of it and it's a
download that they can find I know it's
on the wallet files.com which is your
official
um promotion website that goes through
and lists all of your
yeah it's in the Wallach Revolution it's
in epigenetics it's in
um no I'm talking about a physical
download that they can look at Dr
Wallace that that is the award itself
and all of the information and the
supporting documentations on how and why
you deserved to get that so on
drjwalik.com I believe there's also a
spot where you can take get a link to
that document and be able to save it or
print it is it's definitely something Dr
Wallach that we don't want anybody to
forget who you are because of all the
work that you have done when it comes to
minerals especially the mineral of
selenium okay and so also that award and
the little the paragraph or two that
goes along with that a picture of
um yeah
it's going to be in here the picture
that same picture is going to be in the
in the uh overhead presentation
PowerPoint presentation that can be put
on put on the big screen yes whatever
you want to call it okay great thank you
awesome thank you so much Dr Wallach and
then the next question that's coming up
Dr Wallach and it has to do with a
condition called poor me syndrome that
is a form of depression or it is
depression actually that is killing
people and they talk a lot about having
a single nutrient called lithium orotate
as part of being the cause of that
syndrome so again we were just talking
about individual nutrients and it's not
all about individual nutrients but when
there is a deficiency
of something
then think conditions like this occur so
Dr Wallach
if you were working with somebody who's
150 pounds dealing with depression
what would you recommend
okay
I'm basically need to hear it all the
bad foods that includes your environment
the people they live with okay you'll
hang out with us no fried foodinal
processed meat you know bacon ham
baloney salami hot dogs pastrami
pepperoni jerky all that stuff's gotta
go no oil so olive oil no no salad
dressing no cooking oils now if you want
to eat olives that's fine
pull them off the tree and eat them it's
good but olive oil in a bottle has been
sitting on a shelf in a garage for two
months or six years or whatever it is in
the Heat and all this thing you want to
be drinking that that's that'll cause
all kinds of problems okay then you also
need to stay away from gluten so they
can absorb that includes beer
unless there's beer from Japan and China
and Australia which is made from rice
most beer in America and North America
and Canada and everything is made from
we okay it's another source of gluten no
buckwheat now there's no gluten in
buckwheat but buckwheat has phagopyries
in it which are 10 times worse than
glutens is destroying your intestines no
sugar no carbonated drinks okay that
means uh no even the the soft drinks
okay the diet drinks and also carbonated
water just the I actually had one guy
ask me this morning you mean I can't
have water no you have to have water but
not carbonated water okay you can't have
bubbly water okay it's got to be just
water okay because the the bubbles okay
neutralize the stomach acid you cannot
absorb minerals or digest food stomach
acid the good lord gave us the equipment
in our stomach to make stomach acid so
we could digest food and absorb minerals
you start taking
um
the
um bubbly stuff okay the carbonated
waters and carbonated drinks suddenly
now that's all diluted and neutralized
so you can't use it anymore you're going
to have a lot of problems well I eat
well why am I having all these problems
well that's because you're you're
drinking all these these diet drinks
okay don't do it anymore
and then that's why we have our rebound
we have two forms of Rebound with no no
bubbly in it we have the sticks
um we have boxes of 30 sticks of it has
100 nutrients in it uh 75 minerals and
25 ions amino acids we have the canister
with 36 servings in the canister a
rebound we do have the cans but you have
to pop the tops on the cans the night
before you're going to drink them put
them in the refrigerator putting the
next day when they're flat okay don't
just pop the tops and drink them you
won't over time it's going to not do you
good okay now it's also one of those
things where
I wanted to have it 150 pounds right
yes let's go for 150 pounds 150 pounds
no other health concerns
two healthy Brandon hard packs per month
well Galloway 142 and I have two healthy
and hard pressure take a full dose of
breakfast for those dinner time then two
bottles a month in the MSM to take three
brackets three lunch at dinner time okay
that's gonna support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between Ray bone reachable himself
including the skull very important don't
forget the book it's all in your head
which includes depression okay and then
you want to also
get away oh excuse me you also want
after the um
uh MSM you also want to take the
collagen peptide take a scuba that with
the morning drink scuba that evening
drink to help again rebuild cell walls
and skin and tannins and ligaments and
bone marrow and all that kind of stuff
very important for the immune system and
then because this is a a brain problem
okay depression
I want them to make sure
that they're getting are
synaptives they can take three synaptic
twice a day it'll be two bottles a month
of our synaptic that's going to let the
brain cells talk to each other the brain
cell talks this non-cortisone core talk
to the brain cells and then my favorite
I mean I'm getting so much positive
feedback on this one okay and that is
the I-26
I mean I have people with a dozen
different
problems in the central nervous system
okay
and
you name it and they're getting results
in three days a week or two weeks it's
just like crazy how well the responding
because
again the the I-26 is what's missing
when you have
Alzheimer's disease when you have
mustache when you have gambray syndrome
when you have FTD frontal temporal
dementia which is kind of a new category
of a dementia that's involving in front
of the brain the side of the brain okay
because when they looked at Alison or
disease it's kind of like not uniform
all over the whole brain it's patches
and so Alzheimer's disease you know had
different variations in this and the
other always confusing the doctors and
so we're going to come out with a
production here and whether it's going
to be added to it's all in your head
where we have just a thing for soft
tissue
added to the to the book it's on your
head or soft tissue for about a dozen
different diseases including this new
one we're talking about
or maybe we'll just do a separate book
about the being about the same size it's
all in your head and so we'll have a set
of two books one for the skull and
vertebrae and the other one for soft
tissue in the in the brain is spinal
cords so we'll make that determination
after we get approval for this and and
so forth I'm very excited this is going
to be a big deal this is going to save
millions of people
right now we have a million people with
this disease we're talking about in
America alone
we have 50 000 new ones a year in
America alone we have 35 000 each year
in America alone die from this disease
and just by
employing this knowledge
adding this to our program is going to
be an add-on okay
it's just like
um it's just like um
the I'm I'm synaptive just like I-26 I
don't say throw away all your violence
bills just take I-26 I-26 is to be added
to a complete program
and that's why it works so well okay
because you have to support all the
other stuff going on as well as what we
call the secret sauce to deal with the
featured question okay but you just
can't take that Secret Sauce by itself
and leave out the 90 essential nutrients
that's that's a No-No
right
now Dr Wallach our next uh question
that's coming from a gentleman he's 73
years old
140 pounds five foot seven and a half
he has no medical diagnoses
but his main concerns are migraine
headaches and
low libido
he also
does have muscle cramping
he's got some damage to the the tendons
the ligaments he's got some gum issues
um he has blood pressure issues numbness
and tingling in the feet and hands
so the blood pressure issues are not
diagnosed
um memory and focus
concerns of course low libido and
occasionally has hemorrhoids
he craves carbohydrates moderately not
tremendously but he's always tired
always anxious and
does have some minor concerns when it
comes to allergies and digestive issues
here because he's doing everything wrong
he's doing everything wrong I haven't
heard one correct thing coming out of
his mouth yet okay
well these are just things that are a
result of what he's currently doing so
what would you recommend to help okay
he's doing everything wrong if he wants
to live a nice healthful life and add 25
years of his life he better listen
because any one of these things that
he's describing there can be
a source of
serious incapacitation and our death
Okay so
they're really bad foods no fried foods
no processed meat so oils no gluten so
we burn around oh so sugar no carbonated
drinks even the diet drinks got to go
and also carbonated water okay and
um then he needs to and his body weight
140 pounds I'm going to have a heatwave
48 or whatever it is 140 148
pounds yeah he weighs about the same I
do he needs two healthy brain and hard
pasture month full of something twice a
day these two bottles a month of the MSM
so we take three breakfast straight
lunch through dinner time they're going
to support and promote maintenance
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between
vertebrae bone makes bone itself
including the skull okay
and then he needs uh let's see here but
also throwing vitamin D three some extra
vitamin D three three of those twice a
day to help absorb all these minerals
and put them in the right places then
I want him to have let's see here the
synaptive I wanted to take through those
twice a day so the brain cells can talk
to each other in the spinal cord I want
him to take the I-26 so the brain cells
can talk to each other and the spinal
cord and then I want him to have let's
see here are
Zara test for his sexual concerns I want
him to take our zero test he needs to
take three of those uh twice a day it'll
be two miles a month of the zero test
okay uh that's not by itself but that's
in addition to everything else he wants
it to work and then let's see here if I
didn't say it he needs the I-26 he needs
three of those twice today it wouldn't
hurt to say three three times a day with
his problems okay and then the hybrid
pressure on them to have our ultimate
daily classical so you can take three of
those at breakfast lunch and dinner
that'll be three bottles a month okay
okay the all the daily classic talents
and then I also because he has ALS okay
he he said ALS right
no he did not not on this one okay so
but his migraines are his major concern
okay well that's where the synaptive and
the and the um
see
um
I have ALS on here I think I've got that
list I don't know why
okay but anyway he has many of the
symptoms you know are some of the
symptoms but no diagnoses for it Dr
Wally all right but anyway then I also
want him to drink the two or three of
our servings a day of a rebound if he's
gonna use the cans you got to pop the
tops at night so and drink them the next
day so that there there's no carbonation
in them but we do have the Sticks no
carbonation there's 36 in the Box we do
have the canister there's 36 servings in
the canister there's no carbonation
there and so we've covered
um
I think most of his issues okay I think
you got it I think you got it well he
needs to get back with us in two weeks
and so forth he can start getting rid of
the bad foods right now and when you get
rid of the bad food you'll save
hundreds of dollars a month because bad
foods are expensive bad foods cost a lot
of money and so if you save that money
then it sort of washes most of the cost
of these supplements so it's not like
you're adding more cost to you you're
eliminating the cost of the bad stuff
which allows you to utilize that money
for something good okay
right
absolutely
so let's go to the hand that is up here
with us Dr Wallach and Ryan
go ahead and
why can I not
um it's not giving me the option to
unmute there we go Ryan go ahead and
unmute yourself
yeah we only have a few moments here so
that he is
Ryan can you unmute yourself
yes
all right how may we help you today Ryan
um an update on my hypothyroidism
my hypo my hypothyroidism
um seems to have gotten better as well
as my hypoglycemia so thank you for the
supplements
um number number two um my doctor did
um didn't want to give me an H pylori
test because I've been taking uh
famotidine and antacids for my um
burning stomach
so I don't know if I have H pylori I
don't know if I have an ulcer
um I I'm scheduled to go to a
gastrologist
um I'm not sure what I should do
okay well if you have insurance it
doesn't hurt to go to the gastrologist
and let them do the tests and find out
what's going on in there because
um if you have something going on
because of an infection uh you know you
want to get an antibiotic of some kind
to kill the infection but it wouldn't
hurt okay to take our digestive program
or enzymes okay our ultimate enzymes and
Carol Elizabeth enzymes okay
it's a gallbladder in a bottle it'll
help you absorb stuff it'll help your
your gallbladder absorb the healthy
essential fatty acids so you can utilize
them
um but the also it's going to help you
absorb things absorb minerals and digest
food we call it the gallbladder in a
bottle because we do put bile in it from
the gallbladders a cattle are killed
okay at the at the slaughterhouses and
so there's a gallbladder in about the
ultimate enzymes I only weigh 142 and I
take two or three of those twice a day
I'd say two or three breakfasts and two
or three dinner time I don't have any
problems if I had problems I'd take it
three times a day okay
when you get your test
that is some good news Ryan thank you so
much for coming on and sharing with us
Dr Wallach let's go to I know Hattie had
her hand up here
is Hattie still with us Hattie go ahead
and unmute yourself
nope okay then I'm gonna go ahead and go
to the next question
I'm sorry
I lowered my hand because you said I
thought you wasn't gonna have no more
people and I apologize so but um I think
I anyway without the while like I wanted
to do I'm doing a five minute thing this
afternoon on oils
and I was listening to a video that you
made around saturated and unsaturated
oils
and then someone said to me well Hattie
um all of the good oils like avocados
because avocados are good for you
bananas fruits are good for you yada
yada
but what I got from you was the oils in
our fruits right are
are
saturated oils with a low with a low uh
no the unsaturated fats with a low
molecule level which makes them let me
clarify things because you're mixing
people up here okay good
that's why I called you so basically you
need the essential fatty acids which are
unsaturated okay and so that's why we
have the the let's see here the efas the
EFA pluses
um it's called the gallbladder in a
bottle and I take three of those three
of each twice a day
okay 3dfas and three of the a pluses
twice a day and I'm like I say I only
weigh 142 pounds so I'm taking enough
for a 200 pound 250 pound person
and you need these things okay and so
I'm not I'm not depending on my body
getting everything it needs to make them
I'm going to give my bodies just like
you don't just throw dirt from Texas in
your car and hope the car can make
gasoline and oil and that kind of stuff
you put high quality gas in your car you
put a brake fluid in there you put um uh
stuff in your radiator to prep around
the engine from overheating and all that
kind of stuff and so if you treat
yourself as well as you treat your car
you'll have 25 years of your life if you
just quote eat well and take one so I
eat a lot of count I take a lot of
calcium what about the other 89
nutrients you need okay well my doctor
said I can get everything I need from
just eating well your doctor is not
telling you the truth that's not true
plants do not make minerals they only
need three nutritional minerals are not
occur in uniform blanket around the
crust of the earth they occur in veins
like gold and silver is gold or let me
back up our gold and silver found
everywhere no there's veins
well our essential minerals Foundry
where no there's veins and so the only
way you're going to guarantee that
everybody in your family regardless of
where they live or what they do if
they're going to get all 90 essential
nutrients is to
consciously put it in your mouth
okay and so this is why we have so many
trouble I get so many uh people from the
military calling me okay because they
spend a lot of time in the military and
you know they trust me because I went
through the same thing they went through
and
um even the military doctors are just
giving them okay just here and take some
calcium that's not the correct thing to
do
okay oh take some take some more vitamin
C oh that's not the correct thing to do
well that'll get rid of scurvy but what
about you know the other 599 diseases
you're going to be confronted with okay
and now of course that's why they call
the British limeys you know they didn't
know why but they knew when they
ate limes and drank lime juice they
didn't get scurvy and so everybody in
the British Navy
eight limes and drank lime juice and
that's why they were called
limeys
doctor medical doctors don't even know
that okay why they're called limeys
maybe they lived in a place where we had
a lime you know a line which is
um minerals found on the ground and that
no it was because they were drinking
lime juice and eating limes
well Dr Wallach it is our goal to make
sure that more and more people hear the
importance of supplementation folks
because it is not in our food and there
are over 600 different poor health
conditions that are directly linked to
nutritional deficiencies and there's 90
essential nutrients
two-thirds of them are minerals
and then you have your vitamins
plants 23 you need 60.
that's right so I'm going to get all 60
plus I'm going to go I'm an overachiever
doctor while like I go for more than 212
like you do
a couple times a day but that's that's
our freedom of choice that's correct we
can choose
to have a life of pain I had to know why
somebody who's 300 years old looks like
you're 25.
so sweet I'm kicking you out
have a wonderful radio program Dr
Yin for joining us here on daily with
Doc folks
there is so much that you can do on your
own you do not re need to have the
permission of the doctor
in order to be able to help your self so
we encourage you to take this time and
invest in yourself you've invested the
time now it's time to invest in what is
nutritionally needed to make a
difference and take some action if I
could have those that are taking action
come on with me and those are my
co-hosts for today we have Marilyn
pazera Spear and AJ
both doing a fantastic job
at making sure that people are getting
the information that they need in order
to help themselves
so if I could get somebody put Dr
Wallach in the waiting room so that our
talk doesn't interfere with his radio
that would be fantastic thank you so
much but I just want to do a shout out
to each and every one of you
I mean Maryland has some incredible
typing skills she's a researcher she
loves Health she loves people and I'm
sure she's not the only one in this
world but I cherish her
and if you have skills like that get
back with the person that
invited you to watch this program and
say Hey you know I have some skills that
I would like to use for a greater good
or a greater purpose
love you
and folks the
this is amazing as Dr Wallach talks
about getting phone calls from different
people all day long and he really does
he really does I'm trying to have a
conversation with him trying to make
some decisions and his phone rings and
he picks it up
that's how important it is that he
speaks with people that are reaching out
for
his knowledge and recommendations
and there are a lot of people that are
doing three-way calls
we have some amazing coaches that are
able to use the information that they
have learned through the certified
holistic health coach course
that
gives us the knowledge that Dr Wallach
has provided in a structure that we are
able to plug into on our own time glean
that information and take some tests and
become a certified holistic health coach
where we can confidently say yes
you're reaching out for help I have the
resources that are needed to make sure
that you get what you need to reach a
healthier Journey when it comes to life
if you'd like more information about
that program go to coachwithbecca.com
or especially if you are invited by this
program get back with the person that
shared this program with you as they may
have their own link for information
about that program
and we also have AJ who is helping me on
the whole technical in side of it he is
also managing the Facebook and
uh Rumble and YouTube for the great
amazing people out there and um yeah for
for those of you who are not aware okay
beer
is carbonated
okay and most of it comes from wheat
barley Rye or oats no mostly wheat or
barley
so
drop the beer find a different Source if
it's something you really think that you
need but if it's something that you're
craving it's probably because of a
nutritional deficiency and
um yeah Dr wallach's program helps with
those too so I just wanted to throw that
out there but thank you so much to my
crew today and thank you for taking the
time to join us share it with somebody
if you have not already clicked that
subscribe and like and share
this is your invitation to do so because
there is somebody out there waiting to
hear information and you can be an
important part of helping them and
finding what they're looking for my name
is Becca Dukes again if you have any
questions get back with the person that
shared this program with you
if there is nobody to think feel free to
go to daily with doc.com and use that
contact us subscribe to our newsletter I
I don't sell my list we don't even
bombard you with a bunch of emails but
we do provide information on the replays
of our programming with descriptions and
our we're getting ready to put together
an actual newsletter that's going to be
sending out some useful articles that
give you even more knowledge on what you
yourself as an empowered individual can
do to help improve
your life and your financial life
whether it's physical Financial
emotional all of these above
um you have some power
find it use it and until next time
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign